what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and not only did we get a new trailer
for The Flash today but for some lucky
folks over at cinemacon which is
happening right now they got to actually
watch the movie they screened it at
cinemacon for a selective audience and
what's really interesting about this
that had us all pretty intrigued was
they're showing a non-finished version
of the actual film so a lot of people
were talking saying well they must be
pretty dang confident in this movie if
they're showing a unfinished version of
it but nonetheless we found out that the
people who got to see it would actually
be able to talk about it afterwards
obviously no spoilers but tweet a little
review a little reaction and kind of
give us their overall thoughts and
that's exactly what they did this
happened just a few minutes ago and most
of the reactions if not all of them are
actually really good not just good but
actually pretty fantastic it had a lot
of controversy of course surrounding
Ezra Miller and a lot of people thought
well the only reason they're kind of
keeping Ezra on board and not scrapping
the entire project is because this movie
was rumored to be amazing and it's
looking like it really is amazing so
let's go over and talk about these
reviews
but first big thank you to cook Unity
for sponsoring this video staying
healthy and in superhero shape while
still eating delicious food just got a
whole lot easier thanks to cook Unity
cook Unity is the first chef to Consumer
platform delivering freshly prepared
pre-selected meals right to your door
weekly look if you're like me and you
try to get in good shape but find
yourself too busy to make a decent meal
then cook Unity is for you I go to the
gym often but due to being so busy I
find myself eating out and eating fast
food a lot for convenience but that has
all changed thanks to cook Unity now we
eat delicious meals prepared by actual
chefs tonight I'll be eating the K style
shrimp fajitas prepared by Chef Brandon
Kita the cook Unity chefs offer up a
wide range of meals with over seven
different dietary preference filters
including vegan paleo and gluten-free
the best part is the meals come fully
cooked so all you have to do is heat
them up and cook Unity makes it super
easy through a Weekly subscription which
is super flexible you can pause it skip
weeks or or cancel at any time so go to
cookunity.com Cosmic Wonder or click the
link in the description below and use my
code Cosmic wonder50 to get 50 off your
first order of cook Unity meals to try
them out for yourself alright so we'll
start with Umberto Gonzalez who got to
see it who is with the wrap he tweeted
out stating leave the hype in all caps
Christopher Nolan movies aside The Flash
movie is the greatest DC movie of the
last 30 years that belongs in the same
conversation as Superman 78 and Batman
89 the movie breaks incredible new
ground in superhero Cinema and honors DC
lore of years past hashtag The Flash
that is some serious High Praise with
the exception of the Christian Bale
Batman Trilogy that we got from
Christopher Nolan he states that this is
the greatest DC movie of the last 30
years and he says that this movie
belongs in the same conversation as
Batman 89 which is kind of ironic but
also very fitting because Michael Keaton
is Batman 89 and Michael Keaton is
Batman in The Flash so one fantastic
review then we have Jermaine lucier over
at Gizmodo a senior reporter he States
yup the flash is as good as rumored it's
Back to the Future meets Spider-Man no
way home with all the humor and heart of
the former and action and surprises of
the latter if anything it might be a tad
too ambitious but it's also just
incredibly satisfying heartwarming and
fun I don't know about y'all but I'm all
for Back to the Future mix Spider-Man
that sounds awesome but the line too
ambitious catches my attention we've
already seen that they are trying to be
pretty dang ambitious in this movie they
have the flash they have a couple of
different Batman maybe even more Batman
some that we don't know about there's
been some rumors they have Supergirl
General Zod is returning there's rumors
of other cameos like Wonder Woman
they've tried to do a lot but according
to all of these reviews and of course
we'll get into more it sounds like it
all worked so moving on to Eric Davis
from Fandango he States DC's the flash
is in all caps tremendous forget DC it
is without a doubt among the best
superhero films ever made an Alzheimer
inventive storytelling Fantastic action
sequences great cast so many nerdy
details I'm in tears at the end
everything you want from a superhero
film and more he continued to state I'm
honestly floored it's this good as a
monster Back to the Future fan it has
Back to the Future Vibes all day Michael
Keaton is amazing as expected and this
is the best Ezra Miller has been as
flash Affleck gets some of his best
Batman moments too and Sasha kale rocks
that is really high praise from Eric
Davis of Fandango it says a lot that he
is saying this he literally said it's
one of the greatest superhero films of
all times which I have been saying it
does have potential and a lot of you
have been questioning me understandably
so but if it's anything like what we're
hearing and what we've seen in the
trailer well now trailers as of today it
sounds like this movie is just going to
be phenomenal but here's a reaction
slash review that really caught my
attention this is coming from Rob Keys
Brand NPR director for Screen Rant he
says just watch The Flash at cinemacon
it has some stuff in it you will not
believe and it showcases much more of
Barry Allen's Powers it is indeed one of
DC's best and fits nicely as a bridge
story between the old and new DC EU
franchises it's also the funniest DC
movie now that caught my attention right
there it being the funniest DC movie now
I've seen some of the humor in the
trailers and I do like it it looks like
Good Humor but as intense and as
emotional as some of these people are
describing this movie and the trailers
do give off that Vibe it's very shocking
to hear that this is one of the funniest
DC movies or according to rob the
funniest but he goes on to State the
audience at cinemacon loved the flash it
has some Mega CG heavy scenes and I'm
curious what everyone will think of the
ending the way some things play out in
the flash are not what you're expecting
you may think you know but you don't so
somehow Warner Brothers DC managed to
keep some secrets from us usually they
don't let's be honest but I'm glad I'm
really glad to hear that the flash has
some secrets in it and some twists and
turns that we're not expecting then we
have Eric Eisenberg who is assistant
managing editor or Cinema Blend who said
this I didn't know what to make of the
hype before the flash but wow movie is
an absolute Blast from end to end it's
hilarious thrilling emotional and
surprising what an incredible way to
launch the next chapter of DC movies get
excited now that sentence is really
great it's hilarious thrilling emotional
and surprising again another one stating
that it is hilarious but we also have
thrilling and emotional which is really
the vibe that the movie gives off from
the trailers which I'm looking forward
to I'm excited to see a serious movie
that also does have some humor to it
apparently some really good humor and
then of course another one that says
surprising so they have hit some pretty
big stuff from us and then last but not
least Jenna Bush from vitalthrills.com
says the flash is pretty great and it
makes sense to me now why DC didn't
shelve this one Michael Keaton is chef's
kiss I didn't realize how much I needed
Keaton's Batman in my life again some
really emotional moments here Sasha kale
is awesome I want to see more of her so
some good reviews about Sasha as well
which is something that I was really
looking forward to seeing her play
Supergirl and I'm really glad to hear
Michael Keaton's Batman is good I hoped
that he would be fantastic because they
were bringing him back it would be
horrible if he came back and it just
wasn't a good movie but again the river
views from these major Outlets they're
really good they're not just really good
they are fantastic I've searched the
internet for a lot of reviews and I've
yet to really see any bad ones so the
fact that this movie is kind of
phenomenal seems to be why DC decided to
keep this movie even after all the stuff
happened with Ezra and luckily the rest
of us do not have that much longer to
wait until we finally get to see this
movie in its full completion it sounds
like it's going to be amazing but hey
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest DC news and so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 it's a Marvel Legends
stuff or some DC stuff winner gets to
choose and we pick a winner at the end
of each month don't forget to follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
laughs